Corey Bowie's prowess and speed led her
to the Olympic gold in 2016's 100 meter
relay agent Kimberly Holland remembers
the 32 year old as a Charming Southerner
Who Loved To Laugh she was like a
daughter to me in the spring Holland
talked to Bowie on the phone their last
conversation they were preparing for the
birth of Bowie's baby girl but shortly
after Orange County Florida sheriff's
deputies discovered Bowie dead in her
home during a well-being check after she
had not been seen or heard from in days
according to an autopsy from the medical
examiner's office Bowie was Home Alone
undergoing labor at the time of her
death no foul play was suspected the
report cited possible complications
including respiratory distress and
eclampsia a rare high blood pressure
condition which could cause seizures